[Music]
Scarlett Johansson and Colin Jost make
their red carpet debut as a couple is
the first time you guys have done a red
carpet together how was it what is it
like was it weird unveiling that moment
right bad you know get some laughs in
and join I'm just excited to share this
experience with them because I'm so
excited to see the film I haven't seen
it before the pair who were first
romantically linked in May looked super
in love at the ultimate superhero event
the world premiere of Avengers infinity
war you don't want to Train being in a
movie with this many people is it kind
of crazy when you're on set and
something you turn around you look at
everybody you're like my god what are
all you people doing there
I often ask myself why Elmo also like
how did I get here I feel like I know
why everybody else is here but no I mean
I just I never you know a decade ago
would ever could ever possibly imagine
anything of this scope with this kind of
fall like it's it's absolutely insane
and magical and just mind-blowing
they're unleashing it on the free world
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]